faut-il interdire les abattoirs oui non
solveig vous forcément c'est oui faut-il
interdire un génocide industriels est-ce
que de poser la question c'est pas déjà
être complice du plus grand cri henri
masse de l'histoire mais pas maintenant
maintenant posez la question c'est aussi
être complice donc on pose la question
déjà soir on avait déjà au moins 16 sept
franchement on roule on pose la question
d'une modernité très bien qu'à non mais
pose une question c'est la wii la
transversale side vous rendez compte des
gens qui ont vraiment vécu ça dans leur
histoire dans leur passé ce qu'ils
pensent la bullx relation d'un meurtre
de masse mais et son exécution puisque
en fait les truites qui sont dans cette
vidéo où tout le monde s'accordera
qu'elles sont bien assassiné ces taxes
est un meurtre prémédité génocide
puisque ce sont des gens donc ils sont
voilà génocide et non mais écoutez moi
je bois je suis en forme je suis
évidemment contre tout ce qui fait sur
l'animal mais commencé comme ça en
comparant bah oui avec treblinka et avec
un génocide avec le non jeu franchement
la voûte erdmann entier vous êtes du
temps en une phrase en oeuvre alors une
et non je vous dis petit je fais des
demandes en une phrase et ainsi prévenir
fini en une phrase vous re vous en
faites vous je savais dès le départ que
moi j'entends ça j'avais les jambes pour
moi je rends toujours dans ça vous dit
de fond du coeur avec tout ce que j'ai
vécu
j'ai envie de te quitter le plateau oui
avec win a basculé
noah ça m'allait très bien qu'ils aient
un mot simple et ça me l'année dernière
les ricains c'est un livre de science
s'est rangée de moore et j'ai envie de
vomir quand j'entends ça c'est non on de
dire ça c'est vrai que ça c'est de votre
côté aussi compenser c'est bien pire ce
sont des milliards de 20 ans et que vous
jouerez ils clôturent le débat la cour
qui avait insulté la mémoire des
personnes qui ont des humaines qui ont
subi à chaud mais ça qu'il faut le
comparatif
soyez un peu plus et redis c'est pour ça
qu'ils seraient allés à la pointe de la
lutte animalistes parce que les déçus
rennais sur yvon sortant des camps ont
dit que c'était la même chose ce n'est
pas moi qui la filme donc vous insulter
la mémoire des sapiens au monde qui ont
su bien de low cost holocauste qui veut
dire cher brunet qu'est ce que vous
voyez en face de vous quel est ce que
c'est un homme quand est-ce que cet
autre chose je vous demande de me
décrire ce que vous voyez dans ses pages
à regarder est-ce que ça ce n'est pas en
sommes encore jeunes victimes de viol
issu d'un viol qui a été violée toute sa
vie qui a si bien marathon geste hâtif
qui est subi quelles étaient tes enfants
tu es toute sa vie qui n'a subi que
torture génétique multi nation et
exécutions dans les camps de la mort
s'il vous plaît solveig connais moi le
mot adéquat dit mon fils me décrire ça
alors maintenant visibles dans un déni
sociétal vous et beaucoup d'autres
animalis mondiale
présentation d'animaux mondiale et
attend l'abolition univers rester dans
cette boucherie c'est mauvais pour
vadrouiller toutes les femmes et vous
verrez qu'il soit masculin ça c'est
dommage que vous parlez comme ça moi
j'aime les animaux je me protège g
d'émission sur les animaux puis mangé
aussi peut-être calamité madame vous
êtes une hystérique on va pas parler
avec moi ce que vous écrivez
cette façon vous avez de décrire c'est
contre vous raconter n'importe quoi
c'est dramatique je me fous complètement
de ce qu'il voit il n'y a qu'un qui
compte
il n'y a qu'à elle il a centré voir une
hystérie voilà vous êtes décrit pas de
moi monsieur de millions d'individus et
non madame
imaginez moi à souhait notre colère ne
tarira jamais notre colère sont guéris
et nos larmes c'est ben ali nous sommes
les mots et vous voulez un débat posé
nous sommes au delà de ça vous donnez
commencé avec moi ce que je veux dire
roland hystérie jeu solveig de nicolas
ne sais pas ça mais là c'est
complètement ce que vous dites mais il
n'y a pas un débat à mener calmement si
c'est jugé parce que ça me fait mal
intégristes vous avez pas interdire à
tous les gens de manger de la viande par
exemple même si c'est ce qu'ils
voudraient species ou l'abolition
universelle de l'ado s'agit bien sûr
voilà là aujourd'hui on est en train de
dire à tout le monde est bienvenu
yamamah morges allaman que nous aurons à
cette guerre qui constate amer sanaa
oui nicolas mais non mais effectivement
vous pénalisez enfin vous aviez vous
arrivez à rien défendre en disant des
propos pareils c'est complètement mais
vous êtes coincé entre vous en avez
entendu parler
on montre d'aix vous êtes des nasillard
vous désirez
non mais vous rendez compte de ce que
madame est en train d'oeuvrer pour les
victimes dont ma vie ce que j'ai à ce
que j'exagère vis-à-vis des victimes
mais non mais attendez après ont résonné
dans les villes devraient consommer
raisonnée faudrait c'est un très beau
maintien dans les camps nous on est tous
dans le garde à vue on est tout le temps
procès on est tout le temps en prison
souffrant va libérer les truies détenus
qui sont maires assassinés dans les
camps de la mort et bien la police vient
nous chercher
non mais la résistance en prison